Perpignan
un peu de soleil il enlève son ex
compagne là-bas l'enterre et se dénonce
c'est un peu con
et maintenant j'accueille gaz par pouce
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
enfin vous faites quand même partie de
France 2
c'est une chaîne dont je salue les choix
stratégiques non Taratata c'était bien
c'était bien mais franchement un duo
entre David Bowie est placé vos ça a
quand même vachement moins de classe
qu'un live de Sofia Aram quoi
non parce que cette année France 2 en
terme de programmation c'est ça met une
claque à tout le monde quoi surtout à
ces animateurs maison c'est pas comme
quoi tu vois c'est enfin Sophia c'est
plus une claque c'est une lapidation que
c'est moi je savais pas qu'elle Kaïda
produisait des émissions
cela dit je trouve très courageux de
bosser pour le service public
être soumis à la loi de l'audimat tout
en ayant les salaires de la fonction
publique
alors
je ne vais pas parler que de la
télévision parce qu'on a aussi des
invités
Noël ce soir sur plateau c'est je suis
votre champion là le président camarade
social-démocratovitch
non mais en fait il s'en fout un peu de
votre demande j'ai eu l'impression enfin
il a mis mon debout pour faire le cake
devant les chaînes de montage mais enfin
bon
ça avait relancé le pouvoir d'achat ça
serait quoi je veux dire et j'ai suivi
l'intervention du camarade Hollande
alors dimanche il a découvert que la
France souffrait d'un ras-le-bol fiscal
et incroyable vous savez c'est comme un
chirurgien qui opère son anesthésie il
va voir le patient lui dit [ __ ] ça a
dû faire mal
le plus inquiétant si vous voulez c'est
que moi je comprends pas ce qu'il dit
enfin autant avant les élections je
comprenais l'ennemi c'est la finance
j'aime pas les riches Sarkozy les
méchants ça me parle j'ai acquiesce
enfin
mais là c'est devenu le Gérard Majax du
brouillard fiscal quoi je c'est la
Transfiguration le discours de Taddeï
dans le corps de Cyril Hanouna
alors non mais les gens les gens ils
l'alchent Hollande mon pouvoir d'achat
alors lui il est là il répond j'ai
entendu cette préoccupation
et je veux y apporter une réponse sur la
fiscalité ce qu'on va faire cette année
c'est qu'avec la décote du crédit
d'impôt dans l'hypothèse on augmente la
CSG de 2%. les on va prendre 1,99 pour
pas compliquer et en tenant compte d'une
croissance de la dépense publique gelée
dans son point d'indice de façon à ce
qu'elle dépasse pas le plafond supérieur
du barème il sera rétrocédé à tous les
contribuables je dis bien à tous les
contribuables c'est-à-dire même ceux
dont le quotient familial représente un
delta de 12 si on prend pour référentiel
le temps de maturation d'une fine de
Claire numéro 6
il sera rétrocédé le quart de l'impôt
qui devait être perçu sur une moyenne
des cinq dernières années
[Applaudissements]
et bien sûr je le dis dans une hypothèse
d'inflation à
1,456%. mensualisé c'est à dire pour
simplifier racine carrée de pi
alors l'autre ça veut dire quoi pour ma
retraite
pour la retraite c'est pareil
bon c'est ça
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
qui va être compensée par un compte
pénibilité indexé sur le tiers payant de
votre mutuelle calculée sur un vase le
prix au détail de la côte de porc
du radis selon les saisons car je veux
aussi tenir compte des difficultés que
connaissent nos exportateurs pour
l'évêque
enfin moi je l'entends parler je me dis
mais là en fait il vient de mettre de la
vaseline ou pas
[Musique]
[Rires]
non mais je pense que s'il y a pas de
contestation sociale violente en ce
moment c'est pas parce que les réformes
sont bonnes mais c'est parce que
personne ne comprend
[Applaudissements]
en France qui sont
les Français qui sont les Français c'est
la crise et les gens se mobilisent pour
un bijoutier
moi ce qui m'impressionne chez les
braqueurs de bijoutier c'est leur
rapidité pour choisir les bijoux
ils savent tout de suite ce qu'ils
veulent fais-moi une fois j'ai regardé
un braquage j'ai dit à ma copine vas-y
prends de la graine quoi franchement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après après on dit que le type c'est un
récidiviste
on le sait bien le goût des belles
choses ça se construit pas en une nuit
alors évidemment la famille du braqueur
dit que la confiance en la justice tu
m'étonnes quoi c'est normal après 14
récidives toujours en liberté
[Applaudissements]
non mais il y a beaucoup d'inepsie sur
ce sujet beaucoup on dit que c'est un
truc réactionnaire 1,5 millions de
personnes qui like
c'est quand même vachement rare que des
réseaux d'extrême droite soutiennent un
mec qui s'appelle turc
ce qui est inquiétant c'est que 1,5
millions de like en une semaine ça va
donner des idées de buzz à certains quoi
il paraît que depuis le phénomène des
bijouteries dans le Sud-Ouest on l'a
déjà vu François Bayrou Rodez près des
bijouteries
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'assaut alors il a acheté les voix des
gens pour se faire élire à
Corbeil-Essonnes il faut comprendre
aussi à son âge il tente le tout pour le
tout se faire élire mère de Corbeil et
essayer de faire racheter des rafales à
sa police municipale voilà
il y a un bras de marre on met un
porte-avion c'est bon c'est calé quoi
déplacement Cahuzac veut qu'on lui
rembourse ses frais de déplacement pour
les auditions de la commission des
finances ah bah oui un billet de train
plein d'essence il est con aussi quoi il
aurait refusé de venir il aurait eu un
transport gratuit voiture sirène escorte
et tout team
planète Perpignan
un peu de soleil il enlève son ex
compagne là-bas l'enterre et se dénonce
c'est un peu con
franchement il aurait commencé par la
fin il avait l'après-midi libre pour
faire de la planche à voile
[Applaudissements]
alors on va terminer par la bonne
nouvelle parce qu'il faut quand même
mettre de l'espoir et de la confiance
parce que sans ça il y a pas de
trouver un job la conseiller le
gouvernement serbe pour redresser la
situation économique locale alors ça a
pas dû être très difficile de convaincre
on lui a dit venez ici c'est un grand
bordel
alors ta belle la vie et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu